je vous dis 3 14 116 à votre avis
oh ben je pense que vous avez raison
parisienne non à quoi sert la table de
logarithme à votre avis alors
avoir plusieurs expressions
un genre de pour remplacer un ou deux
musiciens comment peut-on calculer la
valeur de PI à votre avis madame je
pense que ça ne se calcule pas de toute
façon je pense qu'il faut calculer le
nombre de litres à la journée
c'est-à-dire qu'une vache est capable de
donner 40 litres de lait si elle a 4 pi
qui fonctionne bien ou est-ce que bon
bah ça se calcule pas si je vous dis une
masse conique qu'est-ce que c'est votre
avis c'est une grosse fille qui est con
ou quoi une fille qui est grosse qui est
con ou quoi et pourquoi